[Music]
thank you
well thank you all for having me this is
a an amazing honor and I want to use
this time to share a few ideas that I
like to think about and that have helped
guide me throughout my career and have
gotten me out of out of school into into
building companies but also I want to
get as quickly as possible to questions
because I believe that the best sort of
invention the best sort of conversation
happens in this in this dialogue so I'm
excited to hear not only questions but
also ideas that we can share together so
my name is Jack and I never grew up
wanting to be an entrepreneur it's not
something I woke up and you know the
middle of the morning middle of the
night saying I really need to be an
entrepreneur it's something that I never
really never entered into my vocabulary
at all and I've never thought about
building companies never thought about
becoming a CEO never thought about
becoming a leader when I was a kid I
wanted to do some pretty simple things
which I thought were simple at the time
which was I wanted to be a sailor
I wanted to sail around the world by the
time I was 21 I completely failed in
that ambition I want to sail by myself
and have a cat as well again failed with
that ambition as well I wanted to be a
sailor because I wanted to explore the
world I've always had a curiosity about
how the world works and I want to see
the world I've always wanted to see
every aspect of it and really be
wherever wherever I thought was most
interesting and and that was the sailing
aspect for me I wanted to be a tailor
and and this is it not a picture of the
water this is actually a picture of
denim what was interesting about
tailoring was the aspect of craft
building something with your hands that
someone else would delight from and not
being delighted just in the end product
not being proud of just the end product
but all the work going forward into it
right the actual craft of building
something of kin
acting something like denim and I was
always fascinated by denim because it's
this natural journal that you wear as
you wear jeans if you put your phone in
your back pocket all the time it's going
to actually make an imprint so you can
look at someone's jeans you can actually
see how they live how they move and what
they do with their life and I thought
there was just an amazing amazing
concept and and wit really well crafted
and I wanted to be a surrealist painter
and this was a the one that my parents
never really understood all that well in
many ways I didn't either
but I've learned so much from artists
I've learned that you can see the world
in the completely different way in fact
you can make up how the world should
look and then you can build it and you
can paint it and you can actually share
with people and that actually inspires
action inspires people to move inspires
people to think in a very very different
way and I thought that was just an
amazing amazing idea and if I could
explore the world if I could craft
something and really learn how to build
and and how to build a vision of what I
wanted to see in the world I could do
amazing things always and and that was
the concept that I've realized over time
is the most important thing for me to do
is to see a picture of where I want to
go see a picture of what I want to do in
the world and then figure out how to
work backwards from that and to make
sure that every single detail of working
backwards from that I'm proud of
something that I love to do I love the
work not just the end product not just
the end picture but every step along the
way and in that sense also be able to
explore the world and I found this great
quote by William Gibson anyone know who
William Gibson is just by show hands
unfortunately too few sir William Gibson
is a science fiction author and he
coined the term cyberspace he coined the
term cyberpunk in a novel called
Neuromancer and he is this great quote
which I think really captures everything
that we're trying to do in this world as
entrepreneurs as founders as builders of
companies and products and ideas
in that the future has already arrived
it's just not evenly distributed yet
which is an amazing thing to think about
and this is exactly how we run our
companies as well we get before the
company and say an idea that can change
the course of the company can happen
anywhere in the company the future is
already in all of your heads and your
work everything that you have to do in
your life is to distribute it it's to
make sure that other people can see it
it's sharing it with other people so
that it resonates in a way that speaks
to them and then they want to build it
as well right and over the course of of
doing that of realizing that picture and
making sure that I am distributing my
idea distributing my picture to folks I
realize that's the most important thing
it's to have that strong vision to have
that sense of what you want to do in the
world to be selfish to build something
for yourself and then be able to
convince others to do the same and by
showing them what to do we talk a lot in
the valley we talk a lot in technology
about one word and that word is
disruption and this is disruption
disruption is moving things around
moving things scattering it around has
no purpose has no vision has no values
no leadership this is not what I want to
do in the world this is not what I want
to see more of in the world I want
something with purpose I want something
with direction I want something with
thoughtfulness so instead of constantly
talking about disruption I believe that
we should talk and focus more on things
like revolution revolution actually has
shared purpose revolution has an idea it
has values it has leadership at house
direction it has something that people
can see it has an end state that
actually has a positive impact but most
importantly it's a cohesive and and
experience that people can really get
behind and join and sometimes revolution
changes ever
thing and it's loud and it's violent
sometimes revolution is silent and it
moves just as much and move can move the
entire world and just one image one
action so revolution can also take on
the power of you know the individual
there was a someone I looked to all the
time lived a very complicated life did a
lot of great things but also did a lot
of poor things but a very simple action
of collecting salt created a revolution
in the country that actually brought
India back inspired people to take their
own steps inspired people to think in
their own way and to really question
everything that was going on around them
we talk a lot about disruption we don't
talk enough about revolution we don't
talk enough about values and purpose we
talk a lot about founders we talk a lot
about founding moments we put so much
emphasis on the founding moment of a
company the founding moment of an
organization the founding moment of an
idea and these are the rockstars and the
organization's this is what everyone
wants to be and I think that's actually
not reality the great companies don't
have just one founding moment they have
multiple founding moments and just to
show an example of this we would look at
the United States this is one of my
favorite paintings because it shows that
these guys had a good idea but their
best idea is captured in the phrase a
more perfect union a more perfect union
we did not get everything right today
we're not going to get everything right
right now others will come and they will
finish the painting others will come and
actually finish the organization in a
way that we just can't predict we can't
project right now in in fact they did
weed people like Lincoln who completely
changed how everyone thought about
living in a union
everyone thought about living in a
United States of America had a
significant impact and I would consider
him a founding father of our nation of
our ideas we had not just individuals
but also movements like the woman
suffrage
completely questioning every single
thing that we took for granted before
having another founding moment that set
the tone for the rest of the country and
how the country would move forward
JFK not only doing it in this country
but also pushing us to explore outside
of our planet itself and pushing
ourselves to make sure that we're taking
on significant engineering challenges
we're really going beyond what we
consider possible and that is what we
always want to strive for in our
companies is that we have multiple
founding moments we don't have just one
right a lot of people look at biz and F
and myself and this Greendeer is the the
founders of Twitter and then just stop
but the thing is Twitter has had
multiple founding moments throughout its
history
we had one spark in 2006 we built and
rebuilt sand built sand then we listened
we listened to the people using the
service and in fact a lot of what you
see in Twitter today the app symbol the
hashtag the retweet the the word tweet
came from the people using the service
there was not something that was
invented by the company it's not
something that was invented by any these
guys up here we just made it easier
because we were really good listeners we
built a simple utility that anyone could
come to and build their own social
products on top of it and then use it in
a way that made sense to them on a daily
basis tweet by tweet by tweet and with
every single thing that they did we were
able to make that a little bit easier
and make that with less friction and
that increased the usage increased the
conception of all the people who were
going to use a service and going to use
a system so the world certainly places a
lot of attention on these founding
moments but in fact you don't really
need to start a company to have founding
moments you don't need to start a
company to actually take the company in
a completely different direction and a
lot of emphasis is also placed on the
word entrepreneur someone who is thought
to start something new
but if you look at the definition
of entreprenuer it's actually someone
who just takes significant financial
risk in order to create something in the
world it doesn't say you need to start a
company it doesn't say you need to be a
CEO it doesn't say that you need to
build a business says you need to take
significant risk to build something new
and the quote that kind of captures the
way that I've always thought about
building that picture that I want to see
in the world is by Steve McQueen this is
him in San Francisco he only had one
really good quote that's worth
remembering or or mentioning but is when
I believe in something I fight like hell
for it
it's when I believe in something I fight
like hell for it and that has been my
life I've had a picture of what I wanted
to see in the world
and I did whatever it took to make sure
that it succeeded to make sure that it
thrived in both company and in the case
of both companies Twitter started
because I had this fascination with
cities I had this obsession with what
was happening around the street corners
in st. Louis Missouri that I wasn't
present at and I had this obsession
because my parents had always lived in
the city they had a police scanner I
could hear the police cars and the fire
trucks and the ambulances roam around my
city and my parents bought a Macintosh
in 1984 when I was 8 years old and I was
blown away by that and I decided that if
I really wanted to see what was
happening in the city I needed to make
these maps that I was obsessed with move
around and I could do that with the
computer so therefore I had to learn how
to program I never wanted to be a
programmer I never wanted to be an
engineer I just had to do it to see this
idea or got in 14 I actually learned how
to do enough where I could draw the map
on the screen and I could draw some dots
and I can move the dots around and I
figured out how to constrain it within
the streets which was a great day for me
and then I would listen to these
ambulances and there would be I'm at
fifth and Broadway I'm going to st.
John's mercy I have a patient and
cardiac arrest I would type that into my
program I could see the dot move and
that would be an ambulance move in my
city of Santos Missouri so suddenly I
had this picture of the city was doing
and I had added more and more data
sources
I figured out how to get into some
databases that I could actually see some
of these things myself and then I could
put him in my program and then one day I
realized that 16 that there's a whole
industry around this it's called
dispatch so I should find the biggest
dispatch firm in the world and I should
go work there because then I can see the
entire city and I found one it was
called dispatch Management Services in
New York City they just got on public
and I could not figure out how to
contact them so I was by this time
pretty good with computers very curious
curious kid and I figured out that they
had a hole in their system and I got
into their system and I found their
email address list for the entire
corporation and I got the email for the
CEO and I got the email for the chairman
and I sent them in the amount said I'm a
I'm jack you have a hole in your system
here's how to fix it and by the way I
write dispatch software and a week later
I was hired and that was my resume so I
moved out to New York City I dropped out
of school for the first time I went to
NYU I started working on the system I
was loving it because I could see the
entire city now we had taxi cabs we had
black cars we had couriers we had
emergency I could see swarms of taxi
cabs going to the Met for an event it
was just an amazing amazing thing
somewhere along the line after that I
then dropped out of NYU so I'm a double
dropout which I don't think anyone else
can claim in that in the dropout League
I dropped out of NYU I went to San
Francisco and we started a web-based
dispatch firm the company was a complete
and utter failure but the one thing that
I did realize during my time there was I
had all these verticals I could actually
see the city in a very very interesting
way but I was missing one key element
and those were the people where were the
people what were they doing and where
were they what are they thinking and
that's where the idea for Twitter came
from 2001 I tried to build a system with
my roommate 50 which was a little snub
nose pager email pager
I spent a weekend I wrote a simple
program so
could email it it would send an email
out to all my friends that I listed out
and I went out to Golden Gate Park I
said I'm at the Bison paddock in Golden
Gate Park typed in an email I went out
to the service and I quickly learned two
things first no one cared no one cared
that I was at the Bison paddock and then
second no one else had a blackberry so
it was the completely wrong time and the
wrong technology for this I put the idea
on the Shelf in 2006 2005 2006 SMS got
really big in this country because you
could send a message from Verizon to
singular which is the first time you
could cross carriers because singular
was GSM which was what SMS was built off
of and then Verizon was CDMA and they
had no way to talk to each other but in
2006 she actually could so it just
became huge even though the rest of the
world had it for 10 years and was using
it very effectively for 10 years I just
fell in love with the technology this is
a technology that barely works but it's
on every single device and once I saw
that technology I said this is the time
I was working at a the first company I
they'd actually write a resume for which
was oh do a podcasting company and I had
not a care in the world about podcasting
when I joined the company I also learned
that no one else cared about podcasting
at the company so the company had no
direction it had no passion for what it
was doing but had an amazing group of
people including my two co-founders and
they had started bloggers before and
they had a sense of what text mediums
could do so I could bring up this idea
as a very simple idea and said can I
have two weeks to work on it and they
said yes and we built Twitter in two
weeks and the first human written tweet
is inviting co-workers which was
inviting all my co-workers of the system
and then two weeks after that we invited
friends and then invite invite invite
and I just has taken off ever since but
a lot of what you see today hasn't
really changed from those initial two
weeks it's stayed fairly consistent but
it's gotten better and better and better
and more refined as we've learned from
how people are using it and what they're
doing
in in 2008 at the end of 2008 I departed
the company
I switched roles with my co-founder of
he was chairman Iowa CEO he became CEO I
became chairman and I reconnected with
my roots I reconnected with with where
I'm from which is st. Louis Missouri and
I met reconnected with my friend Jim
McKelvey who was my first boss when I
was 15 years old he was actually my
second boss my first boss was my mother
when I was 14 years old at her coffee
store making cappuccinos for people who
didn't know what really a cap chena was
saying Santos was not that sophisticated
at the time and I would make cappuccinos
and I hated coffee and I would serve a
cappuccino and give to someone they
would say this is the best cappuccino
I've ever had and I said really that's
the first one I've ever made so I knew
the bar was very low and I could only go
up from there but Jim came in to my
mother's coffee store and said you know
anyone who loves computers works with
computers and I said I did and I worked
at his office that night and we just
developed this great friendship I went
back to st. Louis in 2008 for Christmas
and we wanted to work together we wanted
to do something together we didn't
really know what we didn't know what to
do together so he had an idea of like
let's build an electronic car I said
okay I have no idea how to do that but
I'd really love to work with you on
figuring it out and then we kept coming
up with ideas and nothing was really
sticking and then he called me in
frustration when dang saying Jack I
he's a glass artist Jack I just lost a
sale because they couldn't accept a
credit card and you know we both had
these phones next to hers he's I phones
and super computers that could do
anything right next to our ears and we
wondered like why was that so difficult
why was it so difficult for Jim to
accept a credit card and we took a month
and we figured that one and that month
was the answer to that question why and
that month was the beginning of square
since then we've realized what we're
actually doing well
actually building and it's all around
making commerce easy so with Twitter we
made communication easy we simplified it
down to its base essence we're square
we want to make commerce just as easy
and the interesting thing about
communication and commerce is I don't
really see a very large difference
between the two
we were actually trading goods as a
civilization before we're using language
to speak with one another
commerce actually was occurring before
communication was occurring and
communication has always been worked on
to be more efficient and more free and
more frictionless and easier simpler and
you see that with Twitter and Instagram
and Facebook and in vine today but
commerce for whatever reason became more
complicated and more abstract and more
expensive and it departed from
communication but when you really think
about what commerce is it's not payments
it's a simple activity between buyer and
seller it's a simple exchange of value
exchange of value is just communication
so our mission at square is to make
commerce as free as communication to
make sure that it goes back to its
natural state to make sure it goes back
to something social something that is
conversational and the way we started is
we looked at the system and we realized
that hey everyone in the world is paying
with plastic now everyone is paying with
credit cards are not paying with cash
anymore they're not carrying their
checkbooks around so you have all these
people using these cards but you barely
have anyone who can accept them no one
can accept them for whatever reason we
didn't really know what the reasons were
but we found out we saw that people were
not only charged for the hardware they
were charged monthly they were charged a
PCI fee they were charged a fee for the
transaction they were charged a
percentage fee which is called the
interchange which is just this giant
guessing game of things that you have to
do and it took anywhere from a week to
four weeks to even start accepting
credit cards right so if the economy is
moving to plastic and you can't
participate as a small business as a
medium-sized business or even as
large business then how do you build
your business up how do you remain
relevant the answer is you can't so
that's the problem that we wanted to
solve immediately because Jim had that
problem because we wanted him to be able
to accept credit cards that was the
picture initially and it was something
that we could achieve we decided that we
wanted to get it down to such simplicity
that someone could download an app and
then under a minute
start accepting credit cards download an
app put in their name put in their
mailing address we would send them a
free credit card reader and they were in
business so this is square you plug it
into the phone and it's very simple and
we actually were able to do that we
actually were able to build the hardware
girls a build the software and we did
that in one month and this was the best
company to pitch and demo in the world
because I would go around to all my
friends and to all these investors and
say do you want to see my new product
and they would say yes I would say well
give me your credit card and they would
say no and I would say well I'll show
someone else then I would say ok and I
would take anywhere from five dollars to
$500 depending on who it was some people
would give me a black Amex and you know
exactly what I would do with that so we
ate very very well in the early days of
the company but the thing is like when
people saw that when people saw that
swipe they said Wow and the second time
they said wow was when they signed on
the screen with her finger and it seems
very simple now it seems very obvious
now but at the time it was seen as the
superpower you just took money off my
card I said yeah check your statement
it'll say Jack Dorsey $500 and they
brought up you know their Amex statement
and they saw Jack Dorsey $500 and just
an amazing feeling and then I would say
see ya but it was a it was a great it
was a great thing because you could
actually like it you had this visceral
reaction to something that you only see
behind counters you only see behind
barriers and now it was right in your
pocket and it really resonated with not
just individuals like Jim
but also larger merchants and and folks
who folks who are growing at the same
time after we built the original credit
card terminal we really looked and
listened to our customers and how they
were using the system and we realized
that the following thing happened on
most counters around the country this is
what most mom-and-pop stores have in
their businesses they have what's
effectively a calculator on top of a
cash box and then they have a credit
card terminal if they accept credit
cards which most don't right next to it
and the interaction that happens for the
buyer is this I walk into this store and
I order a cappuccino and they find the
cappuccino button and they press the
cappuccino button the receipt pops out
and says three dollars and 25 cents and
I hand over my credit card and they look
up and they groan or they sigh and I say
okay I'm gonna take this type-in 324
into the terminal into the machine right
next to it they swipe the card another
receipt pops out
they give me that receipt to sign take
that receipt back take the other receipt
take a coffee card to staple that
together give that to me and then I
throw that away it's a come it's a
complete waste and at the end of the day
they don't have any information about
what just happened all they have is how
much they made the dollar amount if they
try to figure out how many cappuccinos
they sold during the day and they press
the button like the report button the
receipt starts flying out and at the end
like the ink runs out so they can
actually get the answer like the whole
thing is terrible the way they count
cappuccinos is actually the number of
cups coming out of dishwashers right if
they need to buy more inventory simple
simple simple things like that allow you
to make great decisions on how to build
your business oh yeah allow you to make
decisions whether you want to have a
lifestyle company like my mother's
coffee store she only wanted to have two
employees or you want to build a global
business like Howard Schultz all you
need is data you need to be able to see
what's happening in your business and
this doesn't matter what scale you're at
so the only way to really do this is not
to build too
systems but to build one system and
that's exactly what we recognized and
exactly what we did and we built
something called square register so took
all the mess off put something in an
iPad and there's some really important
things that we realized in doing this
number one is that merchants put all of
this attention and craft into their
aesthetic they they really build up
their store and then they have to
compromise at the counter they have to
compromise at the payment system you
know they're so proud of what they built
and then they have to have this these
ugly systems right on the counter and
worse it's right before their customers
like this is the thing that is in front
of their customers when they walk in and
there's a few folks who have realized
how bad this is if you go to any luxury
store you go to like a hermas or a Prada
or armani and you buy something first of
all you enter in this like weird
universe where you can't really tell
what time it is and everything looks
magical and if you buy that you're going
to be a completely different person if
they were to put this on the counter
that would completely bring people back
to reality so what they do is if you buy
a belt or you buy a tire you buy
anything what they do is they say okay
can I please have your credit card and
they take your credit card and then they
go off into the back room and they close
the door and then they swipe the credit
card and they print a receipt and then
they put the receipt and this like
beautiful leather envelope they come out
and they say please sign it's like this
head the heaviest pen you'll ever feel
you sign it like oh my god this
experience is so amazing why can't this
happen all the time they closed it in
one minute please and then they go back
into the back room and then they take
that receipt and they put it in the most
expensive envelope you'll ever see and
they take that out and they hand it with
two hands and they give you that
envelope but it's just a receipt in it
it's a paper receipt but they've removed
everything that looks mechanical they
removed everything that looks like has
friction to contain that experience and
that actually builds loyalty it actually
builds a desire to come back and to
really continue to exist in this magical
world that they created every single
merchant in the world wants to do this
they can't they don't have the
infrastructure they don't have the
basic simple things the other thing that
we learned is that the folks who are
using this iPad their two-year-olds are
using the iPad in fact in many cases
their two-year-olds are teaching them
how to use the iPad right
so if we use commodity hardware that
people already know how to use people
are already familiar with there's no
training
it's just intuitive people spend 6 hours
of their day behind one of these things
right so a better well damn feel amazing
and not something that is constantly
complicating so we focused a lot of our
energy on the merchants but again we
were being quite selfish because we go
to get coffee every day we go to have
food at restaurants every day we go
through all these commerce transactions
that we love every single day and we
have to put up with all this mechanical
crap all the time so if we can fix this
side of the counter we can actually
improve the buyer experience our
experience not all of us in the company
are merchants barely anyone in the
company is merchants is a merchant I
hope they may be doing a site business
I'm not sure but we we've always
approached in this this very selfish way
of let's let's improve the buyer
experience because if you improve the
buyer experience you'll have more buyers
and that means more commerce for sellers
that means more transactions for sellers
but we can do even more so we built the
credit card terminal then we realized we
have to actually build a register to
account for someone's entire business we
have to give them great analytics so
they can build their business up make
simple decisions around it but we can do
more than that we can actually improve
the payment experience and we can make
it disappear
and I got in front of the company one
day and I said I want us to build an
experience where I can walk into a
coffee store I can order a cappuccino I
can take the cappuccino and I can walk
out and on my way out I will wonder if I
paid or not right it should feel that
intuitive and it should disappear
completely and the company came back
three months later and built it and we
called it square wallet and what it does
is you have a consumer with a phone they
download square wallet they link their
credit card once and then you have all
these merchants around
and for your favorite merchants you can
turn on hands-free payment and what that
means is you put your phone in your
pocket you keep your phone in your bag
you leave your wallet at home
you walk up to the merchants you walk
into their store and as you walk in your
name and your face appears on the
register it says Jack is entering the
store and it's likely that he's going to
order a cappuccino because that's his
favorite he gets it every single day so
what the tool we just gave the merchant
is that they can recognize you by name
they can say hey Jack would you like
your regular I'm like whoa how did you
how did you do that how did you how did
you know that this is what Starbucks did
with their entire business they trained
baristas to ask a very simple question
how is your day going very very simple
things and then the barista learns about
that customer they recognize when they
come back in that's what builds loyalty
so every single merchants they use ask
where has this tool where they can
recognize their customers coming in they
can say hey Jack and then all I have to
do is say you know I'd like a cappuccino
you can put it on Jack
they hand me the cappuccino I walk out
and as I'm walking out to ask me if I
want to leave a tip or not right
very very simple on my speed doing what
I want to do I'm actually tipping the
quality of the cappuccino I'm enjoying
right now instead of someone's ability
to enter in to a point-of-sale system
and our merchants have seen a 22 percent
increase in tips because of this very
very simple thing but this is giving the
merchants a tool to build natural
loyalty they don't need coupons they
don't need Groupons they don't need
sales they just need a great product and
they need to be able to recognize their
customer and what this means it's not
just at that place do I have this VIP
experience but anywhere I go that's
using square I can walk in and they know
who I am and they know what I like and
they can treat me like a VIP which means
that I'm going to keep coming back there
again and again and again because it
feels like my place it feels like
something I own and in fact it's another
one of those superpowers it's another
one of those things that when people see
someone walk up to the counter and say
like hey cappuccino please
okay thanks for walking away like
how'd that guy do that like who's he
know who's he friends with I want to do
that and those are the products those
are the products we want to build these
are the products that they give they
give people these superpowers that they
want to show off naturally Twitter was
very very similar in that you can
communicate with the entire world
from wherever you are you could see what
was happening in the entire world
wherever you are it doesn't matter if
you're in front of TV if you're out if
you're in front of a computer all of
that has the power to make you better
and to give you a better experience and
it's so great that people want to show
it off and that's how products really
really spread we think a lot about this
you know this end-to-end experience and
one of the things that we derive a lot
of inspiration from is something that
would find in our own area which is the
Golden Gate Bridge something that we we
have the opportunity to cross every now
and then we really built the company
around this very simple idea there's
many many aspects of this bridge that I
love but going back to something I said
earlier it's not just the end product
that was magical is also the way they
built it if you look at just the end
product for a minute what it is is it's
a bridge it has one purpose it has one
feature and that feature is it doesn't
fall down that's all it has to do it
just doesn't fall down right and most
people who are crossing that bridge
they're not thinking about oh is the
bridge gonna fall down because they know
bridge is probably not gonna fall down
there's gonna be some people who are
thinking of the bridge is gonna fall
down and like why do I have to do this
and it's gonna be an earthquake and you
know the whole thing but they were
actually they're actually protected from
that so the bridges goal the bridges
function is to get people from point A
to point B and most of the commuters
that go on this bridge every single day
all they're thinking about is point B
they're thinking about what's on the
other side like what do I have to do at
work today what's for dinner tonight
like what what am i what are my kids
going to say tonight like you know where
am I going you know I'm going to this
concert I can't wait to get there
they're thinking about point B and
they're thinking about point B so much
that the bridge completely disappears
they don't even notice it right it
served its function it served its
utility it's a utility that does it so
well it's so intuitive that it
disappears completely and that is
magical that's a product those are
products that I want to build things
that are so intuitive and such a part of
people's lives that they disappear when
you're using them right and and that's
how we think about square that's how we
think about Twitter people come to
Twitter for a very simple reason it's
another A to B they want to get some
information from someone or they want to
communicate and share with the world
with square they want to move money from
one place to another or they want to
build their business and our job in both
cases is to make sure that it stays up
100% of the time if we have any failures
if we go down if we have any issues then
we are putting ourselves and our issues
in front of our customers and they're
going to notice it they're going to
start thinking about all the failures of
the bridge they're going to start
thinking about the failures of Twitter
you're gonna start thinking about the
failures of square instead of the
reasons they came to us for so we wanted
disappear disappear but the amazing
thing about this bridge is if you
actually do take a moment to notice it
is absolutely breathtaking when you're
coming down to Sausalito tunnels and you
see the two towers rise above the city
which is normally rising out of clouds
because it's always foggy there and
unlike here which is absolutely gorgeous
today
it's breathtaking and it literally takes
your breath away and you notice that
it's not just a bridge that provides
utility but it's something that's iconic
it's something to be proud of it's
something that everyone who worked on
this bridge is immensely proud of so
proud that they're their grandkids are
proud of it today and that's one of the
most amazing things about this bridge
it's just the story of building it this
is a bridge that is crossing one of the
most tumultuous spans on the west coast
it's this this area underneath the
bridge that this area right here is
about 60 feet deep underneath the bridge
it goes down to 400 feet deep all the
weather is forced right through this
Golden Gate you have these high winds
and you have earthquakes it's the last
place on the planet you want to build a
bridge 1.7 miles span
across the Golden Gate and not only did
they have the ambition and the audacity
to cross this band and to build
something that would last but they also
had the audacity to make it beautiful
something that people would be proud of
1300 people worked on this bridge 1300
people they cost 1.3 million dollars
which would be about I'm sorry 33
million dollars which would be about 1.3
billion dollars in today's money they
gave themselves the goal of building it
in five years they built it in three
years in 1934 which is amazing and it
just celebrated its 30 its 75th
anniversary
it's still up it's still it's still
something that you know we we look at
and we we wonder at and are proud of you
contrast that with what's happening with
the Bay Bridge right now the Bay Bridge
has been working on by over two hundred
thousand people this extension right
it's not over a very tumultuous area
it's pretty pretty simple
it was completely manufactured in China
shipped over here to be assembled the
goal was originally about seven years
it's been over 12 years now
no one is proud of this bridge
no one is proud of that huge amount of
bureaucracy and and the teams and and
all the mass and the resources it took
so small teams can do really audacious
amazing things if they have a vision for
what they want to see they didn't just
build this bridge and said well you know
we need to we need to build a bridge
across and we'll figure out what it
looks like when we're building it we
don't know where it's going but we'll
figure it out no they had a specific
vision of what that would look like and
it wasn't just an engineer saying this
is what's going to look like it wasn't
just an architect saying this is what
it's going to look like it's the pairing
of the two if you give an engineer this
job of building this bridge it would
stay up 100% of the time but it wouldn't
be something that anyone would want to
remember if you gave an architect the
same job it would be something that
would look absolutely gorgeous but it
wouldn't stand up no
could use it right so it's this pairing
between the two that actually creates
something like this there justice
absolutely stunning when you when you
see it in person from every single angle
so we want to build companies we want to
build products we want to build ideas
that have a timeless effortless value
such as the Golden Gate Bridge something
that we can look at and draw inspiration
every single day but every company ever
idea everything that we do has to have
some sort of purpose it has to have the
answer to the question why and and this
is a question that I think is one of the
most important to ask it's the easiest
question asked which is why kids ask it
all the time and it's the hardest
question to answer which is why adults
get so frustrated by answering the
question but if you keep asking why you
keep getting to the essence of what's
most important and that is where it
truly great ideas where truly great
companies come from is the constant
asking of this very very simple question
getting deeper and deeper and deeper
simpler and simpler and simpler into a
great question but that's how you drive
your your purpose and your vision
there's this great quote by Bill Clinton
which really speaks to Squares purpose
and what we're trying to do in the world
which is work is about more than making
a living as vital as that is it's
fundamental to human dignity to our
sense of self-worth as useful
independent free people so when I was
starting square I was really nervous
like how can we attract people to work
on payments it is the least sexy thing
in the world like no one wants to work
on payments no one wants to even deal
with it it's not something that people
wake up and say oh my god I need to work
on payments today I want to
revolutionize payments like nobody says
that but we can focus on what's really
meaningful in payments and it's not and
within the realization it's not about
payments it's about the experience it's
about that end to end it's about
building something that allows more
conversation happen it's about building
something that fades away and disappears
completely so people can focus on what's
most meaningful to them
so before we get into questions I
thought I'd end a very simple founding
story of my own which were at where I
came from my father when he was 19 years
old in st. Louis Missouri started pizza
restaurant with his best friend and they
called the pizza restaurant two nice
guys and they were very nice guys
my father didn't finished high school
his best friend didn't finish high
school they never went to college they
just loved making pizza again they
didn't wake up thinking I need to be a
founder I want to be an entrepreneur
they just loved making pizza they loved
the delight on someone's face when they
were enjoying what they made it's very
very simple very pure and the business
started doing really well because they
put a lot of their heart into it and
they they loved everything they did and
they wanted to preserve their friendship
and they wanted to preserve the sanctity
of the business so they made one rule I
had to hire waitstaff and their one rule
was they would not date any other way
stuff and the first person that hired
was my mother and my father fell in love
with this girl Marsha in a week and
realized that oh my god and I'm about to
break the rule so he went to his best
friend he said I fell in love with this
girl you can the business as yours I
broke the rule and then I was born ten
months later when I was my funding story
so I thought I would end the speech and
the start the questions keeping the baby
picture up so that always takes the edge
off the questions
[Applause]
[Music]
you